I've been sick, so that's why I haven't
been streaming.
I'm back to about 90%. So, I figured
today we're going to try to get some
cool stuff done. Um, one fun thing to
share.
I got my handle.
No more bunch of numbers at the end of
this, at least on uh on X.
So, that's my main platform. So, it's
nice.
Anyways,
uh plan for today. Let's see if we can
get back into this.
Right. So, this thing was making a whole
bloody mess is what was going on last
time.
Yeah, this thing was making a whole
bloody mess because I was getting tired
and lazy and probably sort of sick. So,
let's not do that this time. Let's
actually freaking think about this.
So, I mean the key issue here I think
right is
This has to be a CUDA file
which means you can't have you can't
just like include this thing directly
right
And then it tried to put this in colonel
CU.
Yeah. No, we're not letting it do that
mess.
Yeah, this is actually what we want.
It's just the launch functions here. So,
it wasn't that far off. It just started
to go off the rails a bit.
So, let's check myself.
Yeah, this is relatively annoying, I'd
say.
Oh no, cuz that also produces ch that
also produces a pain.
Okay, I think then we try to make this
header file work.
Let me just I think this is just a dumb
C++ thing, right?
Also, is my chat working? I don't see
any messages in it.
Let me go check on YouTube. Maybe the
YouTube chat's not going through.
Oh, looks fine.
Hey, Pepe. Okay. Okay. Yeah, that's
working.
Like why can I not just find
it's honestly because stack of stack
overflow like not
being updated as much anymore. I swear
it's like the only way to find
information is through the [ __ ]
language models now.
I'm not very good at that at all. I
mean, Pepe, this is a brand new thing to
me.
I'm sure they like it though because
it's um it's a very short and verifiable
task that people understand to be
complex. So, it's like one of those
things where models are very well suited
recruitment ends and I'm definitely not
filling that crap out.
I honestly might switch it to I think
then like do I really want to give
Google money.
I don't like giving uh anthropic money
for claw code because I really just do
not like what they're doing. Um
but this is being a useful tool even
though it's designed very dumb.
Here's your cubicle.
No, I think it's more like open offices
and orgies.
Templated rappers.
A damn rapper and everything, huh?
Why the heck are launch functions like
this, man?
Launch functions.
Why are they like this?
I honestly don't even like that we have
these templated at all in the first
place. I really do not like templates.
No, we're not doing constant. That's
awful.
the room. What's the objective today?
So,
we need to I mean it's mostly
refactoring Pepe. Um, so there, how do I
explain this? There are just too many
moving parts at the moment, right? We
have our CUDA code. We have uh the
launch functions for the kernels. we
might want to support float and bf16 for
some of these. We have to figure that
out. Uh then because that requires nvcc
and the rest of the code's g++ or
whatever there is additional binding
code then torch has its own module defaf
type code. Uh and then there's pi bind
for the python bindings. There is a cuda
a cuda exclusive test. They're like
pretty much anytime I want to change
anything there eight different places
things need to be changed and it's
driving me nuts and it's very confusing.
So the objective I guess today we want
to clean stuff up.
And
I think as far as new stuff, the main
thing I'd like to have today is I'd like
to have this in a place where we can
have
uh more than one environment working
with Puffer. So we can have multiple
different test environments.
We can start doing performance
comparisons.
The other thing I'm trying to think
about is whether I want to have a um
uh if I want to have C++ fallback.
I mean because presumably
the CPU has memory bandwidth as well,
right?
So presumably we actually have faster
C++ code as well than um original torch.
Okay. See, it's going to put this
absolute garbage at the end of it.
Yeah, I hate this completely.
You see what a mess this is?
And the thing that I really don't like
about this is this is basically when
you're doing this, you're saying that uh
human should not be able to edit code by
hand because nobody can edit this crap
by hand.
And I do not like that.
The fact that this thing even consider
this a reasonable solution is
disgusting.
Like we can try this to have something
working for now, but this is just not
and it'll say, "Oh yeah, this is just
standard standard standard." But it's
not standard to add like unmaintainable
crap.
And see, it's like really obnoxious
because I'm going to do this for now,
but I have to remember to take this out
because like this is unshippable.
Here, you'll see exactly what this does.
Watch this.
Look at this.
This is just like templating brain rot.
And what do we have here? Okay, this
one, this chunk, this is the only thing
that's actually fine.
Open code.
Isn't open code um an IDE?
I'm not swapping my IDE.
That's kind of cool.
So what it's their own I mean when
people say agent they literally mean we
wrote four loops over an ll so they just
have open source that chunk of it and
then they use the model for whatever.
That's actually kind of cool because
then that would mean that um pretty much
as soon as you have a decent open-
source model you can directly just
replace their crap.
Well, I'm not going to interrupt my work
session to try this right now, but I
like I might set aside some time to try
this at some point here.
Stop giving anthropic money.
I don't like I actually don't know what
model I would even use.
Holy crap. What is this?
Oh, that's fine. It's just replacing the
template false.
That's fine.
I actually the little line where it says
like clawing, vibing, pontificating. I
consider that like particularly stupid.
So keep but I'm not banging my head
against Claude because the mo like
the problem isn't the model dude right
and this is the pro man this is the
problem with like the heavy LLM users
it's as soon as there's a problem it's
like oh you need a smarter model like no
you need to understand what's going on
here so what's going on here right is
that we have uh CUDA code incuda files
okay And uh we have a couple of those
functions that are templated because
they need to support float and BF-16 and
that's what C++ does for that. And uh
it's supposed to make things less
redundant, right? But then because you
can't easily export templated functions
between uh CUDA code and C++ as far as I
can tell, they end up duplicating
everything and wrapping the templated
functions to be non-mplated. So you end
up with the templating crap and you also
end up with all the overhead that you
would have ended up with anyways if you
don't do templating. And because you
have it in CUDA and in C++, now you have
it in two places and now your codebase
is just a steaming pile of [ __ ] Like
that's what's going on here, right?
So I don't need a model to think about
how to do this better for me.
Okay. So, this is the gross solution,
but this does run. We need to hear this
tough. I mean, exactly right.
Don't replace your thinking with a
[ __ ] model.
I think though for now I don't want to
do do I want to figure this thing out
right
the thing that I don't Okay the reason I
don't want to invest a ton of time in
this right now though is because I
actually don't even know if we need to
keep uh float plus BF-16 for this stuff,
you know.
So, we might just be able to delete
everything because we only need it in
float 32.
And actually this I could get this to
write a timing test pretty simply as
well.
The thing is Bflat 16 is still stored in
in 32 bits, right?
Wait. Yeah, Bflat 16 is still stored in
32 bits.
Let me just double check.
Oh, you dumbass. Yeah, it's TF32.
Okay, never mind. Never mind. It's TF32.
Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm thinking of the
wrong type. Cool.
So there is actually savings here,
right? Because if we launch the kernel
uh with Bflat 16, we cut the memory
bandwidth in half. So there are actually
savings to being able to launch this
with BFL 16.
Cool. So we'll leave this then alone for
now. Um,
do folks want to see me fight this for
the next hour or should we look at the
environment stuff? I got to go use the
restroom real quick. But then um the
thing that I was thinking that would be
more exciting to start on today before
we uh we have to really figure out the
kernel dtype situation. So we have these
environ like this environment hardcoded
in. This is breakout and I was going to
try to get it working with a few other
environments. So we can see the speed up
for like neural MMO and stuff.
I think that'll be cooler.
Let me use the rest room real quick.
I'll be back in a few and then we'll I
think we'll do this unless people really
want to figure out the DT type
shenanigans first with me.
we'll do this for a bit then. I think
this will be the productive thing
anyways. Um,
create environments,
we need to come up with a couple of
things here.
We're not going to worry about the dypes
for now.
This is all the same.
This will just be set from flag.
So,
this has to get passed
Okay, I think what we're going to do is
we're going to pass the end bars.
Yeah, we're going to pass the end bars.
And actually, we can get out of this
one.
Somebody asked on YouTube why we're
getting less streams these days. Why is
the YouTube chat not working then?
It's been glitchy lately. Hang on. Let
me go pull it up since uh so I can have
it.
And you've been getting less streams
these days cuz I was sick. That's why.
Oh yeah, there are a whole bunch of
messages. Why the hell is it like this,
man? Why are my messages not going
through,
Joseph being super busy. No, it's not.
Anish
only Twitch seems to be working. Well, I
have the chat up on the side now,
so I will miss fewer messages.
That's annoying. Yeah, I somebody if
anybody wants to find me an easy to set
up alternative to reream that doesn't do
this crap that I can just run. Actually,
somebody said to just do Streamlabs, I
should do that.
For whatever reason, it's very very
difficult for me to force myself to do
anything than like the main thing that I
have on my mind right now, which is this
project. Like literally, I try to force
myself to do any form of work that isn't
this project, and it's very difficult.
Try that. Hey, Son of Liberty. How you
doing? Uh we're doing
we're going to see if we can get
multiple environments working today with
this. And then also
uh there's still just a whole bunch of
cleanup that needs to be done for this.
and I've been sick so I'm a little bit
behind on this.
I basically have just been playing
Runescape and doing like a little bit of
light admin work. I've just not felt
good at all.
I got sick at the gym, but I'm back to
about 90% now.
got rocked by a cute bronze. That sucks,
dude.
Okay, good.
Cuz I had last about a year ago, right?
I had what I thought was a flu and it
ended up being pneumonia. And it nearly
killed me.
That [ __ ] is
serious.
Conferences.
Oh, but yeah,
it's honestly just not worth it in my
mind.
Like I weigh I enjoy being in Maryland
uh like just for months at a time in the
middle of nowhere with nobody to get me
sick and nobody to bug me and just being
able to like focus on my work and my
health and doing stuff that I'm proud of
is just much better that way.
though actually my uh my warehouse is
more inland. It's not like right right
on the water.
I don't even really need the waterfront,
frankly. I just need like a bunch of
space.
Do my own thing.
Pie dict. No, you don't need this, dude.
What What are we doing here?
Oh, actually
Wait, why? Wait, wait. Huh? Why is it
like this? That float value.
This was stupid. No, no, no. This was
stupid.
Wait, where did I do?
So, I dedict item size capacity. It can
have a void value, an int value, or a
float value,
right?
items
and then that gives you this dictionary
and then what? Cuz it's going to be
dict.
posted hyperball thing. How much
knowledge do you think one needs to
tackle this? Pretty little.
Ben and Sam for sure have enough to do
it.
Necrotic pneumonia. Jesus.
I had um myopplasma
pneumonia which is like apparently that
goes around barracks and stuff. So that
one's like not entirely unexpected.
It's not the same type of pneumonia that
old people get cuz their immune systems
are crap.
It's fine for now. It's a little iffy,
but not that bad. I'd say not that bad.
Just the naming
anthropic.
I don't know why people get the
impression that like I'm a good kernel
dev or something because you see me
doing kernels here. You guys know I'm
like brand new to this, right?
Like I'd written one kernel before this
puffer 4 update.
I'm just able to learn this stuff fairly
quickly.
Don't we still need this?
What's this?
Okay, it just renamed. That's fine.
Session management
session. What do you mean?
I maintain there's absolutely zero skill
involved with using this. There's zero
there is zero skill required for this
whatsoever. Um,
like what I'm doing now is 100%
dependent on my programming knowledge
and zero% dependent on any like [ __ ]
how to use the agent thing.
You know,
[snorts] this is essentially me just
like describing
um well-defined transformations to the
codebase and having this type it for me
without like screwing up syntax or doing
things that mismatch along the way.
Like here, look, this looks like a big
edit. All this is doing, you see, is um
dick set float goes to dick set. It's
very, it's like just a little bit more
than you could do with an IDE's refactor
tool.
That is a very nice trick though. The um
the double calf trick, the fact that a
double contains all the integers.
That is a very nice trick to know.
So if you need to set a value that can
be either an int or a float,
you store it upstream as a double
because a double can contain all the
values that would be in or would be
float
instead of having like a strct that has
an int and a float coding these days.
Uh not really major. If you actually
look at what I'm doing, you'll see
that's not what it is.
Doesn't stir dupe literally allocate
memory.
Yeah. Why does that need to be start
dipped?
And it depends what you're working on.
The only way I like, look, the only
reason I'm having to do this right now
is because I'm working with CUDA and
Torch.
If I were working with like just torch
or just CUDA,
it would be fine. But the stack here,
it's seek environment code through DLS.
Uh we've got CUDA kernels, we've got
libtor, C++, we've got Python bindings.
Everything is super redundant.
So every time I'd say like you know
refactor this thing to be slightly
different, things have to get changed in
10 places
and it's pretty much unavoidable.
When you're watching me write
environment code, you'll see I use this
stuff way less because like I can just
type the damn code.
Perfect. The cast will This is actually
C++. This will just fail if this is
fine. Yeah.
So that's way better, right?
Plus eight.
So you see even for like a new fiveline
function cuz this is actually a new
piece of code. You see I'm like
I'm going back and forth with this
through 10 iterations.
Um,
that's a gross type. So we use auto for
gross C++ types
[snorts]
And now I think that this is like a
respectable little function. Right?
So that's the amount of scrutiny I
subjected to when I have it write
actually new code. And why do I not just
write this fiveline function myself? You
might ask. Uh let's see. So this is the
pi bind API. I don't know the pi bind
API, right? I don't write pi bind
manually and I don't like pi bind
actually and I'm only using it because
of lib torch. Uh and then aside from
that, we also have
I guess the C++ types aren't super
relevant here because it's autoed, but
there were also before intermediate
versions there was weird C++ typing that
I'm also not familiar with because I'm
not a C++ dev, right?
It's really not that complicated of a
distinction though, right? It's like,
are you actually actively thinking about
what you're doing? Are you outsourcing
your thinking?
231N basic RL proper lab cool problems
aren't already solved. Yeah, if you
check my guide um between my ML and
science guide, my ML programming guide
and my RL guide, it will take you
through the quickest possible way to do
that. So, um you pretty much you need to
know
you need the basics of multivariate
derivative calculus. Uh that's what you
need. So
you don't need to be super like you
don't need to know all of your
derivative. Like you don't need to be
able to be great at taking a ton of
derivatives by hand, but like if you see
a derivative, you should have some sense
that yeah, that's about what it should
be. Um you need to not get super uh
surprised when you uh take a derivative
of over a matrix and you get like a
transpose or you get cross terms. There
are a couple weird things that can
happen with matrix derivatives, so you
need to be familiar with that. But
frankly, like that stuff comes up way
less often. What's most important is
that you understand the chain rule. like
that one thing from calculus is what you
need because the entirety of uh ML
frameworks are basically just the chain
rule applied to modules so that you can
chain together different operations like
you can write different layers and then
the backward pass just does the train
chain rule to get the derivatives
backwards. That's all the main math you
need. If you're doing some of the stuff
I'm doing lately, yeah, occasionally you
get slightly fancier stuff, but really
the math is pretty light. What is not
light is the programming. Uh you need a
very good programming background and
that's where most of the time will be
spent, which is why I generally I
suggest that like you start getting into
real programming projects as quickly as
possible uh and doing more engineering
and uh there's a little bit of RL
material along the way that's required.
231N is very good because it will have
you write your own basic autograd and
that will teach you quite a bit
[sighs and gasps]
[snorts]
back on YouTube. See, I didn't do
anything. It literally just like fixed
itself. Oh, I missed a couple messages
on here. Dario said software engineer
will be automated in 12 months. Yeah,
he's lying.
Yeah, Daario and Altman are just liars.
It's that simple.
They want money.
Tiny Torch is a good way. If that's
Carpathy's thing, then yeah,
honestly, you can write your own
autograd in C. It's not that hard. Like,
okay, when I say it's not that hard,
like the thing that's hard is actually
just getting the damn derivatives right
for comms and a couple of the other ops
that are weird. But if you just wanted
to write like um a couple activation
function functions in a linear layer,
that's a really good exercise and you
can just do that in C. Heck, you can
even go do that in CUDA. The code will
be almost the same and you will learn a
ton by doing that and you'll actually
produce code that's way way faster than
Torch for small models.
an M or just anything in anything
serious is fine. If you want to do RL at
the same time, building up to more and
more complex M is a great way to do it,
you know, but any like reasonable
programming projects are good. C is just
very nice because C
Doing C is a very good way to guarantee
that you don't waste your time.
Essentially,
C just doesn't give you a bunch of
[ __ ] you don't need.
Then Microrad,
I haven't seen at Liberty. So,
So, this now takes an end name.
Oh, cool.
Yeah. So, this is actually kind of what
we need. Let's see if this still runs.
compilation is very slow. We're actually
I think we will see if we can do
something about the compile times.
Oh, you know what? I probably actually I
know what's wrong.
There we go.
Just forgot to rebuild the the uh shared
doge
10 mill.
Perfect.
Okay.
So far so good.
There's going to be some jank around
different data types to handle,
but for now this is good.
That's what I was checking
actions.
Ah, so yeah, that's going to screw with
stuff, isn't it?
There you go. Let me use the restroom
real quick. Stomach's a little off. I'll
be back.
Incompatible pointer types.
This supposed to be float.
I actually think that I'm going to be
able to make very good use of this um in
updating all of the environments because
it's very strongly verifiable. Like what
I'm basically going to be able to do is
make uh take one environment, write a
simple test function for it, and then
say, okay, do this for all the
environments and make sure that they all
run correctly.
And then we'll be set,
which is nice, you know.
I like that.
I see. So, yeah, it's weird.
Yeah. Yeah, it's weird. Um
Not everything needs to be specified,
right?
Yeah. So, like all this stuff, this
should not have to be in here, right?
Let's
see the config input size is wrong.
this is like way way way nicer. Um, like
this. I'm actually very much enjoying
the models because I basically get to
describe the exact refactoring operation
and just have it done faster and not
break my train of thought
though. I do it should be a little
faster. You know, the biggest upgrade
frankly would be if this just happened
instantly. If we just had like this
instant and faster compile times, we'd
be set. What's this?
that's fine.
Let's move some stuff around.
So, I actually I really enjoy the uh the
refactoring process. What I don't enjoy
is having to manually
uh type the code and then track all
instances
of stuff. though I suppose
it is still important to track to some
extent the number of instances of stuff
because you want the the final code to
be as simple as possible and have things
in as few places as possible. I guess
what we'll see is like when I go to look
at the final code I'll see if I missed
anything from doing it this way. That'll
be the interesting comparison.
I mean I still think that there would be
a use either way.
I'm going go grab myself a nice uh
another mug of tea.
and a few as well. Once we have this
working,
oops,
wrong one. Silly.
Okay. Well,
let's give it some additional steps
cuz that's like ridiculous.
Yeah, that's like a that was like a
weird config if I recall.
That was like a really weird old config.
Uh, it trains freaking 16 million steps
per second, which is interesting.
I'm trying to remember. I think this was
like so this was different architecture.
This was the uh the sample efficiency
work I was doing.
Where's like the old
is that 20 mil right there?
Yeah, 20 mil.
Let's try this one.
Well, let's see if it's just the thing
that What?
Just we'll try to add complexity for no
reason.
Let's see if this gives us a proper
message at least. It It would be funny
if it's just this right here.
I wouldn't be surprised if it's just
that.
It should be tolerant to that though.
Okay, it does learn and it trends over
10 mil.
So, we'll have to do uh we might have to
reweep and stop, but it does learn.
Our train's over 10 mil.
that's a quick commit done. So,
I think we bind a few more test
environments.
So, you know, we make sure this is
working for some different environments
and then we'll see whether we spend more
time porting M's or we spend some time
on the kernels or what. But, you know,
I'd like to have a few more of those uh
those environment set up nicely. There's
quite a bit left to do. Let me go grab
myself a good mug of tea, though.
Okay,
so there are two environments
that I really want to bind.
Um, but they're hard environments, and I
think we should probably bind at least
one simpler environment first.
Let's go take a quick look at what I can
pick from.
Oh, we're just going to do snake.
Obvious, right?
It's discrete space.
It's discrete. That's fine.
How do you start design buffer system
itself? Learn about systems programming.
It depends at what level you mean from
that. Right? So like
what portion of it, right? All of puffer
lift is
that's like all my knowledge.
I mean, that's like a million things
that I have in my head. If you think if
you give me like a specific thing, I can
give you a more directed answer.
How's it going with cloud code?
Uh, the way I'm using it now, I'm very
much enjoying it.
The way that people suggest me like tell
me that I should be using it. No.
like absolutely not.
Uh it's a sign char
does torch not have
torch has in date Okay.
How are you using it? I'm basically
using it to apply welldefined
transformations to existing code.
I'm not using it to solve new things.
Something between the CN and the Python
C.
Oh, um yeah. So that's just a
combination of um relatively simple
systems programming and then honest the
best skill I have is being very annoyed
by complexity. Right?
That's mostly what it is. It's just like
learning some basics and being very very
annoyed by complexity.
You just end up thinking more about how
to make things simple than most people
do. And that's how Puffer is as simple
as it is. I spend a lot of time on it
because it really just it it's not like
I spend a lot of time on it because I
think it's the right thing to do for the
project. That's part of it. But at a
very fundamental level, complexity just
annoys me.
AIdriven, it's not AI driven coding.
That's not what I'm doing.
Okay. double actions float this
then snake C.
Okay, it's actually fine from here
because the A is in here.
do the inference for like
embedding models.
I
have to look at what this is. If it's
I have to look at what this is. If it's just the embedding layer, then sure.
Yeah, I think this is the wrong mindset.
It's not as bad as other stuff, but it's
still the wrong mindset.
like I've been very happy using it to
apply clearly defined transformations to
my code, right?
Like anything that looks like here's an
existing thing where it's done over
here. do this exact thing but to this
other piece of code over here is pretty
good.
Anytime you give it more freedom than
that, it starts making a mess.
So, I don't think this is going to train
yet.
See, like the problem with most of these
articles of people describing how
they're using um AI tools is they're not
actually using AI tools. the AI tools
are using them and they're doing very
very little on top of it.
All right. So, this is now where we're
going to start having um problems.
Continual learning will be solved soon.
Uh well, it has to be freaking defined
reasonably to be solved.
It's actually kind of wonky if you think
about it. Um
the thing that's a little bit weird
about the continual learning setup to me
SD is
so some of the really big models they
just do one pass over the data anyways
during training. So like you could very
easily imagine just adding more data to
it and then oh okay it's fine at least
up until a certain amount.
um
it just then becomes an infrastructure
challenge. But now the thing that's a
little weird is because now you have all
this RL in the loop, right? So now
there's the question of like
well if the is the new data that you
want to inject actually pre-training
data or RL data you can't really go back
and do more pre-training once you've
done the RL.
So I think in some sense the original
continual learning problem is perhaps
easier than anticipated at least for
very large models. Um for small models I
don't know that there is a solution
other than just like continuing to train
on all the data like the old data as
you're also training on new data.
But I think the significance of it has
been massively overstated.
I don't think like continual learning
necessarily.
I don't think that is the thing from
preventing that's preventing these
models from hyperscaling.
I don't know if this is um spy alt or
something um Vancouver, but I'm just
going to ban you if you keep doing this.
So, just stop.
I think an external system will be
required
inherited continu. I mean I think that
like RL is a much more interesting case
in which to study this in in any event
studying this in language models is
probably not the right spot to study it
at all.
I'm actually very happy with how we're
set up um with what Puffer can
contribute to the science cuz like we
can just run way more experiments faster
and cheaper than anybody else and that's
going to be doubly true in Puffer 4.
I whatever. They find like somebody
who's gone a little bit wonky. It's
like, "Oh, but this guy made this." It's
like, "Yeah, whatever.
That doesn't mean I'm just going to
blindly believe everything."
I did start writing uh you you all will
know though I did start writing the uh
the article with my thoughts on on
models and cloud code but it's going to
take me some like writing sessions to
get through it
for
Okay.
Yeah. So, here's Yeah. This is where we
have the uh the big issue.
We have this typing issue. Now, let me
think how this should work. So, the
problem here is that we have different
environments have different types for
their observations.
And this is actually crucial because you
want to be able to have um shorter types
to save the bandwidth.
size.
What's this? OBS type.
It's a macro, right?
I think the future of ads is going to
just be garbage. It's already garbage.
I've seen like this is why I'm very
happy I have for the most part I just
don't get ads anywhere because whenever
I happen to see any it's like wow I
don't want to share a planet with
whoever made this garbage. What in the
actual hell?
Why drinking that much of a coffee when
you get the same caffeine? Would that be
more optimized? know, cuz this gives me
something to sip on
where I actually get some fluids and I
don't dehydrate myself throughout the
day.
And it's also basically impossible for
me to have too much caffeine with this.
I had like four monsters a day when I
was in undergrad. That [ __ ] is not good
for you.
You will do permanent health damage.
I actually have a much more reasonable
amount of caffeine now.
The one double shot of espresso won't
hurt you.
No, this is just tea. This is just like
fairly weak black tea.
How much water do you drink per day?
However much water is in all these teas,
it has very little caffeine for the
volume. So, it's not just dehydrating me
when I make it with this amount of
water.
Favorite white noise and a latcha
latcha. Welcome.
Yeah, I've been sick, so I haven't been
on.
D type equals equals float.
Okay.
Can macro it. We can void star.
It's black tea with milk.
It's black tea with a splash. Like it's
a very small amount of milk.
I think what we have to do here, right?
Well, let's see.
It's kind of sketchy, honestly. Like,
I'll show you the problem. So this thing
here, I'm thinking we we either have to
make this like templated or we have to
do this with some fancy macro over the
type, which is gross. Um or we have to
do uh this has to be a void star.
Let's actually go through this one.
LLM.
I got pretty good results.
What did you do?
My initial clawed code stream was the
most depressing [ __ ] I've ever done,
man.
I don't know if you saw the followups.
I'm using it in a completely different
way from that original stream.
What did you do with this simple loom?
I haven't been on Twitter. Twitter's
kind of just been cancer lately.
Yeah, dude. Triton is not minimal. What
are you doing? Wait, what?
Uh man,
well at least I'm not criticizing your
code by criticizing this crap because
this is clawed.
[ __ ] hate this project structure so
much.
This is not simple LLM. This is like big
tech prod like uh enterprise fbuzz
thing.
Okay, this is less bad. This is just
like dense torch. Whatever
torches,
not actual torch. It's mimicking torch.
It's funny though that like mimicking
Torch is actually completely like bad
because Torch is actually a bad design
for Hyper.
Stolen from VLM.
It didn't even write its own kernels.
Oh, that's hilarious.
And I like I really don't like the like,
oh, let's just let Claude think for us
thing or do everything. I've been having
way way more fun using Claude to just
like
people are saying, "Oh, use it as a
tool, but then they'll use it to replace
their thinking." I mean, actually use it
as a tool. Like, use it to quickly apply
well-defined transformations to your
code that would take you a long time to
type out and you'd get a couple syntax
things wrong and have to recompile and
break your train of thought. Like,
that's what I've been using it for
lately. And um I mean, the results are
we now have 10 million step per second
training. So, it's nice.
Give me a tiny. Yeah, I actually thought
that you did because it looks kind of
compact.
Did you see Hightail? Yeah, it looks
awesome, man. I'm really happy that
project succeeded.
Wanted some practical
wanted some practical experience from
RL's
month of Sunbardo, Kevin Murphy, and Toy
Project. Nurmo seems fun and
challenging. any general advice on
exploring this field? So, neural MMO is
the hardest out there for now that's
fast. Um, it's a pretty tough one to
start on though. It is just bound to
puffer. So, you can use neural MMO 3.
Don't try neural MMO 2. It is too slow.
Neurmo 3 is a thousand times faster. Um,
honestly, all of my best advice, man,
is on this article right here.
Like if you do this, you will get into
the field and it will be dramatically
less painful than it would be otherwise.
Everything there is free as well.
Tried going branded. Yeah, man. I don't
recommend that. It's awful.
But wait then how how when you do the
mem copy
yeah this is fine
also add how use it now yes I'm going to
do that but if you just watch what I'm
doing here you will get the sense of it.
There's and I want to be clear, there is
no skill like there's no like learning
curve for the LLM or anything like that.
Like that wasn't what it was.
It's a very simple decision. It's are
you using a tool or is the tool using
you?
It's really that easy.
I think I agree though with this thing
here that um the best thing is we do
just make this void star.
We're going to see where this rabbit
hole goes at least.
I think that this should be the easiest.
We only have to do it in one place.
Maybe two if we do actions, but I think
one place is easier.
And on GPU, it should still be void
star.
Oh,
I see.
It's kind of gross.
Create its own docks and then every time
I see
No, I don't like that, man. That's too
high level.
I don't like I don't like that. That's
way too high level.
for your UI.
I mean that's fine with my work, right?
Like what I do with puffer requires me
to simplify and simplify and go lower
and lower level and make things faster
and faster. Going higher and higher
level is the opposite of what I need to
do.
Vibe coding. Yeah. So, I'm not doing
that.
And frankly, I think that the reason
that you want to vibe code the UI is
because um the web APIs that you have to
use like the web UI toolkits and stuff
are so garbage. Like I don't blame you.
I wouldn't want to deal with that stuff
manually either. But then in what I do,
right, like the goal is to produce
things that people do want to deal with.
Ray is a great example of this, right?
If you want to try graphics that
actually don't suck and that you want to
do stuff manually with and like learn
things, Ray Lib is awesome for that.
Basically train cloud code as your
intern. No, I would give interns way
bigger I give interns way more stuff
than this. Are you kidding me?
The guy I will be bringing on as an
intern this summer kicks club's ass.
intern is like, "Hey, go make this drone
fly with Puffer Lib
and do it in a way that's like actually
good and produces fast, simple code.
Claude basically gets treated as um you
know better intelligent.
Oh, cool. Yeah, material science is one
of my top um
top things that I'm interested in for
um for RL.
The thing is like I'm not really
tracking what people are doing now cuz I
can virtually just guarantee you that
the stuff that I plan on doing with
puffer lip for science is going to be so
different from what anybody else is
doing anyways that it's virtually
irrelevant.
This is kind of one of the cool things
about going like a really really far off
the beaten path is that you can
basically guarantee that anything you do
is going to be completely novel. Oh,
I don't like this macro, but it's fine
for now.
Right now, simulation amount. Mhm.
I don't know. I'm generally I'm happiest
when I just get to do things. It's like
a very fine line though, right? Because
like there are people that like to do
out there things because they like to
solve interesting problems. whether or
not they actually end up being
applicable to anything in the real
world, right? And then there are people
that like to solve real world problems,
whatever the method is. And like, you
know, if it's just making something
that's a little bit better than what the
next guy is doing faster, then they do
that. I like to solve things that are
like out there that have real world
applications, but are kind of way off
the beaten path. That's what I like
doing.
So I kind of get to just like work on
stuff in peace and not kind of have to
participate in the whole zeitgeist.
I guess this is fine for now. I'm going
to have to think of a better way to do
this macroing
log.
Uh I think I have one that would be open
to that
Um, depending on how negotiations go in
the next couple weeks, honestly, we
might be capped.
Like, we already might have we already
might have as much business as we can
handle for now.
Depending on how the current
negotiations go.
I personally already have plenty of
client work and I'm already like, you
know, wanting to spend more time on the
core.
Most likely that just means our prices
will go up once I launch on Puffer 4.
What the heck is this OP six that was in
there? That shouldn't have been in there
in the first place.
That's weird.
Why small policy more steps better than
large policy less steps?
Uh yeah, sure. This paper.
RL needs more samples
than supervised learning.
There's less signal per step
essentially.
Limitless is a movie. I don't watch
movies.
I've been kindly delivered some
breakfast. That's nice for a change.
I don't think there are other options
that it'll come up with. Let me think
about this and eat some eggs.
and of course it gives me the worst
suggestion possible. Oh,
This one is type and this one is void.
Right.
Let me think about that. I did a degree.
Welcome. Having some breakfast on the
side here and thinking about how to fix
this like weird macro thing.
Hey, Lance. Oh, right. Yeah, I was
looking. I couldn't find the damn where
the heck it just banned you on YouTube.
Is there like a block list? Do you know?
I can do that now while I'm eating.
I basically I like fat finger banned
him.
Oh, I think I see it. Lance. Boom. There
you go. You're unbanned.
Let me save there. You should be
unbanned.
I just fat fingered it.
So, there's like a right click option in
reream that like blocks and I just I fat
fingered it when I was trying to like do
some other thing.
Can we macro the type itself or is that
stupid?
So, Moon, our um the latest version of
2048 is pretty good. If you join the
Discord,
Kyouong has been doing a lot of work on
that.
So, 2048 is pretty challenging.
Not to get 2048, but to like actually
get really high score. It's got this
nice log linear curve.
Most of the other ones are actually
pretty easy.
Uh, we also have there's a project Jess
has been working on with Spencer.
They've been working on selfplay for
chess, but that's probably more advanced
10 mil plus. Yeah. Well,
we wouldn't be able to train the size of
the Dota 5 policy in a few hours, right?
We'd be able to train that number of
steps in a few hours.
If you resume the same conversation with
it and you haven't asked it a bunch of
stuff in between,
its memory is in tokens, not time,
right? So, its memory is not dependent
on time. It's dependent on like it's
dependent on the text that it currently
has in its buffer.
4K LSTM they reduce it they didn't
reduce it to 1K they increased it from
1K to 4K
it's 168 million parameters I believe
chest selfplay similar to alpha zero uh
it doesn't use search crit
so it's pure on policy it's um pure RL
with no
Let's see if we run into another problem
with this.
Now we don't need more macros, which is
nice.
It's just the size of the freaking DT
type.
It's a little janky, but I think this is
like
because otherwise you end up with the
void star not casting correctly, right?
I think because we're doing these as
standalone DLS, it works.
Wait, what?
Let's
give you some cub to try to train 168
mil on complex task. I don't think
there's much use in that though, man.
Because like
we can run hyper pram sweeps. Actually,
this is something we're doing with
puffer 4 is we're going to check the
scaling and I don't think it has a
favorable uh data compute tradeoff
to scale to that size for most problems.
I actually suspect that they would have
ended up with a much smaller model um if
their environment were much faster
and also if they'd had some of the more
modern architecture tricks as well.
Presumably their policy was quite uh
quite slow and inefficient.
If I tell Claude like, "Hey Claude, do A
to B." It's pretty good. But if I tell
Claude like, "Hey, Claude, do A to C."
It'll then do like A to D to E to G to X
to I don't know what failure state, you
know, to whatever. Uh then back to C
somehow
a debris. We're not using an LSTM in
Puffer 4. I actually suspect this
architecture may scale better. So, we're
going to see in this one.
But in uh in Puffer 3, I remember it was
not worth going above 512 hidden dim.
Write out A then B then C.
No. What you should do is you should
write out A to B and then you write out
B to C.
What if I I Yeah, Jess, we're doing um
we're refactoring this so that we can
have like all the different M's working
with Puffer 4 now.
So there is a problem for me to solve
here. for a moment.
I didn't think the minstm architecture
was as good. They had this weird norm
operation on it that I didn't like.
Mru has been good. We actually there was
one substantial gate change that I had
to make to Mingru though to make it work
because you either need RMS norm or this
like additional gate change that I made.
So it's not exactly Mingru anymore
just because I hardcoded everything for
breakout for testing.
It's a little complicated actually
because they're much stricter
requirements on how we handle the types
of all the different buffers now. So,
I'm figuring out a nice way to do this.
Okay, I see. So, this is the problem.
This can't get included here.
Hyperball is NGPT
is just what do you mean it's just NGPT
See, this is much nicer because this is
like, you know, I uh I tried a few
things. I use this to apply the changes.
It realizes that there's a problem. It
suggests [ __ ] fixes and then like I
get the actual fix
cuz this goes in binding and I think
this works now.
How do you discover the adjustments in
PO?
So the
um what is it?
the sampling thing filtering change was
inspired by I guess it's like
generalized or adapted from the gigaflow
paper.
Um and then once we were doing filtering
I went and I grabbed prioritized
experience replay and just adapted that.
So I mean it was like it was kind of a
several things that existed but then
substantially adapted and tested
extensively.
And like the um what is it? The puffer
advantage function was essentially me
just applying important sampling
was it was it clip sampling or whatever
to um
to like the per element computation of
advantage. And it turned out to be very
similar to retrace but for on Paul or
mostly on Paul whatever.
Ah, that's fine.
Scree looking cast, but no biggie.
I mean, is this like slightly obnoxious?
Yes.
I think this is the easiest way to do
it. Uh, I don't I can't think of an
easier way that you would go about this.
I guess if you didn't have macros, what
would you do?
Like the end would just tell you what
type it has. You'd set some flag, right?
And then depending on the flag, so not a
macro, just a constant. Then you would
conditionally like every up would be
conditional.
Assigning from
assigning to char from floatar.
Breakout still works and snake doesn't.
Just some weirdness.
See, it was nice to see it back on the
timeline. See you, man. Man, good luck.
He's got um you should go check him out,
guys, if you're looking for compute.
He's got a pretty nice little interface
for uh buying compute at the lowest
price from all the different vendors
with a nice setup.
And there we go. It's uh
pay more thing.
That one lasted a couple streams though,
right?
Two, three, four.
I cut it.
both reduce wait both
reduce training to hyper hyperspherical
constrained optimization.
norms are fixed and learning proceeds
entirely through directional updates.
So
I don't know if that's a good thing or
not frankly if that's even how it works.
Um
when you say both oh ng see I don't know
ngpt
no one is preconditioning
that's quite front.
That's not even the right command, my
guy.
Oh,
I guess it did apply that one small fix.
Cool.
And now this is probably still not going
to work because we don't have multi-
aent.
So presumably this hangs or does some
weird thing.
would be 96
1.
little bit at least
even though this is like not at all the
setting it's designed for
there.
Okay. And it's very fast yada yada.
Right.
So now we basically need to get the
numbum agents thing.
So thankful I added domain randomization
chess.
H
I suppose that makes sense. Jess
suppose that makes sense. Let let's
figure out this this thing and then I'll
go and get myself a cup of tea.
The way we do this now, we have like
numb snakes or whatever.
Okay. Okay. So, I didn't really think
about the
I didn't really think about this from
the the C creation side,
did I?
Well, for now, what we can do is we can
add multi- aent,
right? We can just add like um
I mean, it was like adaptations of
existing things that I thought would be
promising plus lots of extensive
experimentation, right?
the gigaflow paper for the filtering
which didn't work for LSTM so I had to
substantially adapt it
and then um prioritize replay made sense
to go with a filtering based thing right
and then the advantage stuff was an
adaptation of importance um like clipped
important sampling
and it was specifically added Combat
over sampling will prioritize replay.
Let's see how this thing is supposed to
work. So you make
M of I. Where does M's come from?
You allocate your M's.
We do it this way for now. We just do
the thing for mental, right?
Yeah. So this is like the commented
thing, right?
just do everything will just be no
agents.
I don't think it actually finished the
update.
We make that total agents.
There's a little factor to do there.
If we can get this thing working though
today, this will be nice. Like if we can
just get a whole bunch of the M's
working, then we can actually start
testing stuff.
And this is actually here. This needs to
be fixed. This is still blocking.
Oh yeah, it's just redundant.
Yeah, it's totally just redundant.
That's fine.
16. Oh, it's hard coded to Way too many
amps is a problem.
Yeah, it's probably just it's spawning
like a stupid number of environments,
I'm sure.
Don't think it's an M4s though.
Oh no, it is
mumm agents.
Does this actually train though? Like
this should be super easy, right?
Yeah. I don't think this is actually um
wait episode return and score.
Oh, wait. No, score is what we want,
right? score is the uh the snake length.
So no, this is actually this is good
score is correct here.
This actually is training quite well.
Yeah. And then this should be uh
training very quickly.
Not though
presumably like the block sizes or
something are screwed
It's probably just the launch arms being
like too big of blocks.
I'd be I'd imagine.
This is a little sketchy because this is
like an easy place to screw stuff up.
Though, if it does get screwed up, we
have um
I mean, we'll be able to know
immediately.
I mean ultimately this is just like
changing the tensor shapes a
Oh yeah. Um, by the way, people, if you
have not started Puffer Lib on GitHub,
please do. It's a great way to support
my work for free in about 5 seconds, and
we are almost to 5,000 stars.
which would be pretty freaking awesome
because like um
like what are the biggest repositories
in RL like 9K?
This has been around for like many many
many years.
How many are missing to reach
5,000?
Oh, that's doing something
kind of something, right?
Well, see now the thing is we don't
know. Um,
it's also different policy as well.
So that's now annoying, right?
we have one hot.
Okay. So, we do have the one hot policy.
Okay. So, I think we have to sort out
models next, right? Because like
otherwise
Yeah, we we got to sort out models next.
No big deal.
Though, actually, I think it's weird
because it does like at least mostly
work with um
Let me try one other thing. If I do like
256 ns, what's that?
And the num agents per n would be what?
Um, four
16.
Switch them maybe.
It's very unstable though. Presumably
something screwy going on.
Presumably.
I guess one thing we could do to check
would be like
Hey, welcome
re ne reached nearly alpha zero on go
with pure selfplay and off call.
I don't get how this would be possible.
Why would it not be possible? It would
be a ton of compute.
Uh, Netis is legit. Net is actually
quite legit.
But what the hell is this new like this
algorithm? I don't see anything in it.
These are 2080 Ti.
That doesn't make sense.
Well, first of all, it's entirely
irreable
because it's like
apparently they just like kept doing
like they kept screwing with the latest
model.
You can definitely look for stuff in
here, but I'm very suspicious.
Appendex.
No appendex.
I mean if this result is actually true
in any sense though it would be very
encouraging
everyone do the 18 residual blocks
for go.
Yeah, that would absolutely
catastrophically nuke speed.
I'm pretty suspicious of that for
non-pixel lens.
Like one thing we can do for that
Spencer is just once we have some stable
MS for that we can just do like numb
blocks in the reset as a hyper and sweep
it. Shocked by the claim. Yeah, that
it's sketchy.
That's like suspiciously.
I don't know about that one.
I don't know about that one, man.
Unstable with four. Yeah. See, so this
totally crashes.
And then if I do this,
let's just make sure this one is stable.
Cuz if this one's stable and the other
one isn't,
it'll tell us something.
I'm gonna let that go for a bit. I'm
going to use the rest room. I'm going to
get a cup of tea. We're going to fix
multi- aent and uh then we're going to
port over a couple new environments. I
actually I'd really like to get the
driving end working and I'd like to get
neural MMO working and we probably have
to do custom policies as well. I'll be
right back.
let's go
try
terminals are never set
in snake.h.
So we'll set that after.
But
I think this is before I was even
bothering handling terminals. It's like
the first major end or first not even
first major end first end in puffer.
I mean, I guess they could also be uh
when we create the buffers,
create rollouts, horizon segments,
segments, hybrid up segments.
Yeah, I'm looking at the same thing as
it's looking at here.
Get segments.
There is a damn segment
Figure out what the heck is wrong with
this.
We need multi- aent so we can bind
neural MMO and drive.
I'd like to have both neural MMO and the
drive work today. That would be nice.
presumably shouldn't be too difficult.
There is the sherinet thing that's a
little weird I think in drive.
Get this batch total agents divided by
the number of buffers
I wonder if we can tell based on the
speed.
Would that make sense?
What? 4096.
So six mil.
Yeah. Once we get this working though,
then we'll be able to pretty quickly um
start getting the other ends ported
over.
Be very nice.
Like, it's nice to see how all this is
coming together.
And it's it's always like the fact how
the refactoring stage is easier to make
faster. The problem with refactoring is
it takes forever. Like I actually really
like the refactoring process. I hate how
like slow and manual it is.
bash
48 buff versus two. That sounds that
like looks good to me.
what else it would be.
What else would this be?
I think what we can do to figure this
Oh,
Okay, we can do this.
Fine by me.
Well, hang on. This one we want to check
the uh the apples to apples,
which should be this one.
Wait, which should be Four M.
Four snakes each.
We're expecting this to go over 100 and
just sit there
if it's correct.
Yeah, this exact same behavior as
before.
Yeah, I think it would be the roll out
stuff by now
would be my guess.
While it does that, I'm going to think
about the models.
Yeah, I think it's just going to be we
add a basic interface for this and um
we add some if statements for now.
Yeah, I think those match.
I don't think that's the critical bug.
Okay, I think we have a rough order of
things to do.
I can see like in my head pretty much
what everything should look like. I'd
say
We still have to handle multi-discreet
actions.
We have to handle a few other things,
but it's pretty good so far.
No, it's not this. Yeah, it's
floundering.
I think we go do the model stuff just in
case.
We'll just go do the model stuff and
then we'll see if that makes a
difference because we are training this
with a really stupid model right now.
I guess it could technically have some
weird some weird effect with it. I
wouldn't think so though.
Like if I just open up my local real
quick and I just do like um
Yeah, it like it learns really quick,
right?
I am seeing 256k.
Does it has two Is it 256?
Where the heck does it have this this uh
configured?
No, it's 128.
I guess the OBS encoder is just really
freaking big.
11 by 11 by 8. like a thousand
does. Not yet. That that that adds 100k
per full.
So, it can't find anything wrong as far
as I can tell. We'll go do the model
stuff and then that'll give us a very
clear check as to where this instability
comes from because it could technically
be something else, right?
Yeah. Sort of floundering and just
wasting tokens.
I think what it's going to be then is
we're going to have
we just add like encoder and decoder
interfaces
So, yeah, it's wrong. This is an
independent thing.
It's completely independent.
Isn't it going to be worse than one
search? Maybe. It's still a damn good
selfplay benchmark environment, though.
It's actually kind of unclear. Like if
you make the environment fast enough,
right,
it's a very good benchmark either way
because like you know you're doing
explicit search as part of your
algorithm. So how good can you make your
algorithms without explicit search?
Because without explicit search is
substantially more general.
It's false.
It just copies everything.
That's fine.
And then why does it have N64T?
Oh, because I didn't do it there. This
is fine. We'll do that.
We'll deal with these N64T [ __ ]
things after.
Then default decoder is now a decoder.
Accept an encoder pointer.
Uh, this is not quite what I want.
Any module.
Oh.
It's like designed around it's designed
to be object-oriented, which is dumb in
the first place. And then it it does it
in the worsting way possible.
It's okay. We If we have to fight Torch
a little bit for this, it's fine.
I mean, I obviously wouldn't do it this
way.
Well,
that's fine. Actually,
that's fine. It can be a module.
And then
do this update
register module linear. It's fine.
What are we doing here? This value
function.
Uh why are we deleting the value
function?
Oh, because Yeah, because we replaced it
though.
That's fine.
and presumably we will have some
annoyances with torch on this. Yeah, but
that's essentially what I was uh
envisioning
because now you just pass the encoder
and the decoder to this thing.
Didn't update the
binding.
creator of G2048M always returns to zero
for terminals on purpose.
It's being changed to zero right after
being set to one
before the function ends. Really?
You sure?
It should be in here.
It should be at the top of step. That's
such a common bug as well.
Okay, fine. Stupid bindings. Not
everything needs to be exposed like
this.
Let's play Flappy Bird. It's literally
like my suggested tutorial project.
Like, don't expect it to be a super
useful end or anything. and Puffer will
just instantly solve that.
But it's literally my suggested tutorial
project.
those bonkers.
Okay, so we need to reweep a bunch of
stuff now.
This is what happens when I'm like off
doing 40 things for a while. Things get
stale and weird.
Presumably re sweep plus term should be
better.
This is puffer 3 0.
Why does it say puffer 3?
No, it's still screws up.
I mean, this is the original config,
right?
How is this slow?
Wait. 2.7 mil.
Weird.
Very weird.
Which is this snake? Eight gigabytes of
RAM enough for sweeping. Yep.
With pretty much everything. It is maybe
one or two M's. Not
sweeps aren't done. Um
we don't do parallel jobs on the same
GPU.
No more catastrophic failure.
the 4 mil out of the box. Not terrible.
Uh now, why is it unstable is the
question. Why is this not nicely
for us?
if I just do this, right, I bet this
works.
I mean in that case then like do I
really know which what's the problem?
It is training.
I mean, that is training.
I do wonder why it's a little bit
slower.
Presumably it's getting hung up in the
end.
How about the number of actions? Is that
a thing?
and size.
That's weird, right?
Act equal act size.
How do we know?
How do we know the num logits?
policy input size numbum actions right
hypersnum actions Oh,
hello.
Is this not
There you go. So, probably it was just
learning to move in one direction, which
is much easier with one agent.
Something like that, I'd imagine.
Or it could be memory alignment. Could
have been a bunch of things with that.
But whatever. We're good. We are good.
And look again,
it tries to freaking return act N.
actually this one it might actually it
might be justified in doing this one
right
okay this one's actually justified the
other numbum obs didn't need numbum
actions okay well you can do that for
now fine until I think of something
That ought to fix Pong from being screw
as well.
We'll see if this actually stabilizes
though. Could be other errors too.
Definitely this one.
The heck is this?
Oh,
annoying.
Search plus RL.
What? Why do you think there's not Oh, I
didn't see that. Why do you think
there's not much research turning
around search plus RL like alpha zero
style projects? Uh there's the I think
it's Chinua or something. There's a
whole Muse what is it efficient zero
line of work.
The problem is that their codebase is
absolute garbage and it's really
freaking hard to implement those
methods.
Um and also it's like
It only works on very specific classes
of environments. No matter how you do
the engineering, it's a pretty
restricted approach is the annoying
thing. And it always takes a ton of
compute. So there there basically
they're just a whole bunch of things
going against it.
Do pawn and breakout both have three
actions? They do, right? Yeah. So then
actually pawn was already correct. We
got lucky.
Hyper is probably still different.
I don't know if it was bindings or the
uh the one of the binding files for
sure.
Oh, literally
you idiot. Look,
don't worry guys, it's AGI.
[laughter]
Forgot to update the freaking signature.
some weird slow config, but whatever.
Um,
See, it's just super unstable there. If
I do this though, I think it's stable.
Workflow.
Yeah, exactly right.
That's fine. You still need to have
control. And also it's specific to this
exact thing that I'm doing as well, ICE,
because like you have to sort of keep in
mind that this is this is a very very
messy codebase because I have I've got C
environments, I've got CUDA kernels,
I've got C++ lib, I've got pi bind to
the Python trainer, I've got a lot of
moving parts
and there's also like their DLL
boundaries. There's the CUDA C++
boundary. There are a lot of different
things here I'm dealing with.
Uh, okay. Interestingly, this is
actually super unstable right here. The
single agent is super unstable.
That wasn't true before, right? Single
agent training super unstable.
Could just go fix the terminals bug real
quick.
Yo, Ank.
You'll flex. You better have something
to flex if you're calling me.
Oh, I spoke too soon.
That's annoying.
I am curious though. Um, if I just do
this, what happens now?
We can go try the breakout per just real
quick because you never know.
Um,
you never know, right? like the breakout
params might just fix it.
Like we probably do need to reweep a ton
of stuff now.
Something is just very unstable here. I
think
Well, I suppose we'll just see which M's
work and which MS don't. And that will
probably let us narrow um
narrow in. So if I run this,
7.7.
Yes, close to what we expect.
There's what I'm working on.
New bindings, stability,
profiling,
all that.
Is there a road map for each release?
Um, this one is C++ backend
10 million steps per second actually
quantify where we're spending all our
compute and then constellation
which is our uh our new like large scale
data visualizer.
That's puffer four.
We're going to have to port the network
over.
All right, I got to go look at what this
thing is.
I think I did this mess. Actually,
this is my mess to clean up. I'll figure
it out because this one is a very nice
benchmark and it's substantially faster
than neural MMO to use as a benchmark
and it's still quite representative.
Here's a restroom and grab some new tea
and I'll be right back.
Definitely not end of January, Jess.
Maybe not even February. There will be
um it'll be stable enough in February
for you to play with it, though.
Let's see. Let's figure out what the
heck this thing is doing. So,
decoder.
Decode actions.
What do we have for this?
Oh, it's not that bad, right?
It's literally just like your standard.
And then what's the hidden size on this
thing?
Yeah, literally import that. That's
super simple.
Wonder what will help checker self play.
I mean you have the um you have the
slime volley end right Jess
that it's not turnbased.
Got that one.
Yep. This is the exact way that I have
this
Yeah, it's not using our fused kernel
though.
Yeah, this is bad because it's not using
our fuse kernel.
Well, we can just say let's just have
them be fused.
generalizable trends and selfplay versus
non selfplay.
Uh
head funky.
Yeah, this is the problem with having
everything being a little off, right?
Like you either need the M to be known
good or the polic like the RL and model
to be known good. It's very difficult
when everything's a little off.
Spencer is testing good baseline AI.
Maya's trained most human move.
Yeah, he was telling me about that. I
mean, that sounds like everything is
going according to plan. The research is
hard. Yes,
this is why I do so much engineering.
Like whenever I can reduce um whenever I
can reduce problems into engineering,
it's much better. It's a lot more
consistent.
Okay, it's much slower, which is
expected. Right
now, the thing that's a little tricky is
um
yeah, this is like way slower, which is
a problem.
Looks promising. I'm going to test it
later. Yeah.
Really
missing
Wait, what?
Oh, why is this [ __ ] in here?
And no wonder this [ __ ] does not need to
be here.
Go away.
There we go.
Okay. So, this says 1.7 mil
for G2048.
and vecum m is oh this is 16km as well
though
okay so 1.7 mil with 16km All right.
Okay, we definitely should not be
slower. We should be much faster.
Do you think a reasonable hidden size?
Uh, I would believe that you see
improvement at 256.
I would believe that you might see
improvement at 512. It would be
interesting if it goes higher than that.
Typically, our fancy M's cap out around
512.
to include. Yeah, you can include like
in the sweeps or whatever. Yeah, if you
don't know it,
for sure.
Target's a really nice one to bind,
right?
That's a pain though, handling
multi-discreet. What else do we have
that's not multiddiscrete?
We have neural MMO, but like
connect four is supposed to work pretty
quick.
Use that as a quick check.
Triple try it as well.
This one doesn't need a custom nut,
right?
Okay, I guess it decides to do cat or
whatever the hell.
Oh, I forgot that the connect form is
like stupid slow.
Yeah, it's a very easy end. This is why
we don't use this, man. Cuz the AI for
this, like the opponent AI is so
stupidly slow.
Hang on, let me go check in a second
here.
Okay, so this is broken. Lovely.
Let's go look what this is.
Grab the
what kernels.
Oh, this. Wait,
wait. We aren't using the RMS board
backward. What? Hang on. The original
kernels didn't work
for this.
Okay, since these are a huge number of
changes, I've got to ask, are you a
colonel dev or is this like 100% vi?
I'll check it either way, but it's going
to tell me something very different
cuz those are the kernels that we need
to be faster.
But like a couple of the ones that you
uh you've edited like we didn't have the
numeric checks even passing for yet.
Like the PO loss kernel would be nice.
The the biggest one's the fuse scan. I
do like writing kernels. Okay, let me
check. So this is the most important one
right here. This fuse scan op is very
very important to us. Um
It uses checkpointing.
How does that make any sense?
I recompute. Did you run Did you run the
numeric checks on this?
Because we do have tests to show the um
that the that this is numerically
correct.
The two things that we want to see right
are that the training is still stable
and that the numeric checks pass.
It's the data it needs.
Wait. So, AAR
Spuff
So, wait, why is that better? I'm so
confused.
trading memory for summary. But there's
no me like
buff cur is equal to wait buff cur.
This is a slow operation though. The
recomputee operation is like
this is supposed to be a pretty slow op
like I'm not sure
what does checkpointing get you because
this is Still
chunk end
minus equals checkpoint. Oh, okay. So,
wait, but you're still doing the entire
sequence.
I'm very confused.
Jonah, have you run the the numeric
checks on this thing?
I'll be dramatically more interested as
soon as I know that the numeric checks
pass and that like at least breakout
still trains correctly
because like for instance I
intentionally I didn't mess with any of
the uh the fast math intrinsics at all
because I was worried about
This would be a very significant
contribution if this is still correct
right here.
And which other ones do you have? So you
have
this one would be nice but the thing is
the PO kernel is like this is not
numerically stable yet. And then the RMS
forward and backward is currently not
used. I'm not sure if you looked at the
code though. If you made it this much
faster, we might actually be able to use
it. Um,
so RMS norm is basically we're not using
it right now because it's slow. If you
have a fast version of it, it might
actually be very useful.
Intermediate data that's used. All the
chunking says we don't need to
much because we just recmpute. Yeah, but
I timed those ops and I didn't think
that those operations were fast.
I guess yeah, it's possible that the
memory bandwidth is worth it. Like it's
worth it for memory bandwidth, but like
when I timed those ops,
like it seemed like it was actually
pretty compute heavy.
So, let me show you where the test is.
Because again like if you have this
thing still like training stable I'll be
very very interested immediately.
Um so we have this where is it scripts
where is it profile?
So we've got this profile kernel script
here
right uh you can also run setup.py build
profiler in order to build the profiling
script. And then we've got this profile
kernel CU.
This does speed test. So this is nice
for speed test. I think one of them has
correctness checks in it. I have not
ported all of the correctness checks,
but we still do have right here in test
microbench. So this thing has
correctness checks
right here. Um like where's where's an
example?
Like Okay, so here's test fuse scan,
right? There's your inputs and then it
does test kernels and it will give you
the numerical diff between the torch
version and our version. So the two
things we need to know, right? It's like
it's got to be numerically about the
same or better as before. Um or at least
it's got to have stable training.
And the most important kernel is that
fused scan kernel. Uh, Mingru is also
like Mingru is important, but Mingru is
mostly just pure memory. Like that OP is
pretty fast as far as I can tell.
The fuse scan op is the one where I
think that a lot can be done, but it's
kind of hard.
What GPU to target. I've been running my
tests on a 5090.
Uh, 4090 is fine.
Any of the consumer cards like that are
probably good.
It shouldn't matter that much though I
wouldn't imagine because like these are
all elementwise kernels. We're not
actually using the tensor cores
at all.
We're not even element wise. This one is
sequise parallel. But like still
and I will say so uh because I don't
want to discourage you here. If you
actually are able to make the kernels
faster and keep them numerically
correct, that is a major contribution.
And it's very likely that if you have
some experience, you'll be able to do
that. I'm a new kernel dev,
but the numeric are important like
otherwise you just stabilize training.
So if you get back to me with those and
say, "Oh, this is actually correct."
then I will immediately like merge it
into a branch. I'll test it out on
stream. We'll see if it's stable. And
I'll probably have a few more test m
stable. So, we'll be able to really like
make sure it's good
tomorrow this weekend. Awesome. I will
be streaming all day on Saturday. So, if
that is helpful, I'll be around.
right here. This like feels a little bit
unstable.
Okay. So, there's some colonel junk,
right?
Can I take uh can I put photographs back
on at least?
Yeah. So we can see we actually still
have some screwy numeric here because it
works.
It works without um the custom kernels.
So, we're not using this one. I thought
the other one should be stable.
It is actually kernel numeric though, it
seems.
Oh, wait. Now it works.
Oh, okay. I see there's just a tiny bit
of numerical jank somewhere.
Yeah, cuz that's working. Cool.
So, that is a connect 4 24 seconds.
Let's go fix Pong. You know, I want to
like figure out what's wrong with um
Pong actually. So,
okay. So, yeah, we have a lot of things
wrong with with Pong. Um num ms
go to 4096
like this.
And then I believe it was supposed to
be.
We can try also with and without the uh
the kernels on.
Okay. So, that didn't do anything,
right?
Uh, this doesn't optimize at all.
That's interesting.
Probably have like the wrong number of
M's or something weird.
Try this. I think the original phone
should work.
This 2 million or 20 million? 20
million. So why is it that bad?
Well, we don't have max mini. We don't
have this max mini batch size thing like
this anymore.
Oh yeah, but those kernels are really
needed
otherwise. What? How is it that freaking
slow?
I don't know how on earth it's even that
slow.
This is like the easiest task ever as
well.
Okay, this is what I was remembering,
right? So this is 12 mil steps.
So this we want this to solve, right?
This this should solve.
And then uh what is it? um updates or
something the mini batches
that we need to provide.
So let's see icon
this is 4092
or no 40964
eight eight mini batches I believe is
correct
uh hidden size is
not altered. So it would be
there.
That's way better. Right.
There's your 4 second solve back. I
don't know what the heck we were doing
with those other params. I think that
was from like weird constellation stuff.
Um, so that's a 4 second solve.
Okay. And that's a two second solve.
Way better.
Let's see that again. Don't blink.
You'll miss it.Oop.
Done. 10 mil step per second. Though I
think that it needs the uh the posty
valve. Either that or it needs to be
retuned a little because it doesn't
solve every time.
That's 21 right there.
But that's pretty nice.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
A little bit of numerical jank maybe,
but pretty good. Pretty good overall.
So, what's up with Snake?
You know what's up with Snake?
initial state. Really,
it's annoying.
Because the thing is this is like a
whole custom
custom annoying policy, right?
I just do this. Can I still learn some
[ __ ]
Let's just make sure we can actually
solve this, you know.
Hey, bet. I'm mostly better.
I'm back up to um
I don't know. I'm back up to like 90%
I'd say.
All right. So, there's our basic snake
net thing.
Interestingly enough, this one doesn't
train either.
So, something weird happened there.
and you're muted. I'm back up to like
90%, man.
Yeah.
Okay. So, this is not training.
Um,
Oh,
you know what I bet happened here?
I bet we broke all the M's.
Well, that's what's going on at the very
least.
We'll go make sure that our config is
reasonable, I'd say.
Let's go do that first.
Nothing yet, but it's um there's some
more
goal uh have several M's bound and
working
and some refactoring as well.
This is the same config. Yes,
I don't see no mini batches in here
though. That's a problem.
Yep. So, this is not updated for Puffer
4.
Uh let me If I can compute that real
quick. So it should be 4096 MS
96 M.
It's like just super unstable.
Let me just make sure.
No, it's not just our kernels. You see,
there's some numerical junk either way.
It seems it's not just the kernels.
Um, what was our policy size?
policy name is snake,
but I'm pretty sure that it was like a
really stupid
policy, right?
Well, it's multi-agent and like
semicompetitive, so it Yeah, but you can
still get some good results out of it,
and it's still a nice test on.
You know, I want to just make sure that
this is actually the multi- aent jank
because,
you know, we might just it might just be
the end.
and then we're going to just do 4096 m.
See if this is stable.
Okay. I mean, this is still janky,
right?
So, I don't think it's the end
necessarily. I think it's our binding
still, but it's not just the multi-
aent.
So, let's not waste time then on that.
like a number of things that could cause
that. Right.
Let's go find another M to do.
I'd like something else that's multi-
aent
with um but the thing is we need a
single discrete action space is multi-
aent
yeah continuous all right we don't have
that
do we have Anything that's multi- aent
with single discrete action spaces that
we know we can train quickly.
MOA. No, I think MOA is multi-discrete.
Go is single agent without selfplay
It's got float ops as well.
I'll be used to play poker.
Yeah, sure.
I'm going to go get myself one last cup
of tea. We'll bind our wear and then I
want to get the more complex M's in
today. We shall see. We'll be right
back.
Okay.
Hey, that guy. How's it going?
I mean, if you look back at what I'm
doing with it, this is a I'm describing
a uh a precise transformation of the
existing code
that's essentially applying a template
based on other things I've already done.
Right? So like watch the actual
modifications.
Change from int and uh int and unsigned
char to double and float star. Okay.
Replace all occurrences of that as
needed.
Look who's adopted LMS. Yeah, just not
remotely in the way that idiots were
telling me to.
And it also depends on the project as
well.
Like for this I have I have CUDA I have
so I have the CUDA to C uh C++ barrier.
I've got the C environments. I've got
the C uh the C to C++ via DLL barrier.
I've got the libtor torch C++. I've got
pi bind to Python. So and then I've got
tests on top of these. So pretty much
any individual change uh requires
updating in like eight places.
So that's the main issue with that.
You'll get a lot better value from Cloud
Pro. I I thought that their like their
limits were [ __ ] man.
I'm just porting various M's over that
guy for testing because we're testing
140.
Not that many casts. That's fine.
Okay. So, this is literally the exact
code from the other file. Paste it in
here. And then all it had to do was go
template match this new thing at the
top.
Right.
fix for terminals.
I want to actually Wait, did you train
it or did like I thought we had to
reweep. You said it doesn't train,
right?
need to re sweep.
Yeah, but like pushing something that
breaks training on an end without
pushing the uh the sweep is not helpful,
right? Because then what's going to
happen is I'm going to forget that we
have to re sweep and or it's going to
turn out there was something else weird,
right?
So, what I'd want is I'd want that I'd
want that PR with the new hypers and
like the new train curve where it's like
at least as good as the old one.
What in the hell?
My god. What are you doing?
like [snorts] literally can't even
handle stupid as basic tasks sometimes
Hey, look at that.
And hangs.
The original do that
I seem to remember there being some
weird thing with that though.
Yeah, this one hangs as well.
All right, so um we match
we match PF
Oh man,
lots of cycle weird things.
Any thoughts on LSTM handling history
versus stacking?
Uh, LSTM should handle history.
It's possible there's some jank thing
where it works better stacked, but
you're going to screw everything up in
the process, including bandwidth.
Apparently, ourware hangs, which is fun.
I mean, we have this now working like
this is a match curve though, at least.
So,
it works as well as it does in Buffer 3.
Speaking of which,
I I just did it on two machines, two
different versions, and yeah,
annoying.
there saying
so
annoying.
Okay. Um, that does mean that we have
multi-agent working though.
So
Multi-discrete sampling.
I'm do the neural MMO bind.
Diagnose the hang. I'm not going into
ourware specifics right now. Actually,
room for improvement over CNN's similar
kind of replacing um CNN's are really
slow on the encoder side I've noticed.
Yeah,
somebody would have to benchmark it
though. Like what you'd want to do is
you'd have to compare
um
you basically have to compare flop
efficiency of small comps
to small uh linear layers or small min
layers and see which is worse.
Can I not just do this?
Let's do this myself.
Yeah, this stupid thing. Forgot to add
forgot to add that completely
Why do some of the top AI conferences
have such high acceptance rate
less than 5%.
If conferences had a 5%
acceptance rate, um, the vast majority
of PhD students would fail their PhDs
and you'd probably just not have people
doing PhDs. And also, the funny thing is
like
the select the selectivity is basically
just a lie anyways at these conferences.
Um because the review process is pretty
much just noise
at the moment. There's almost no signal
in it.
And also selectivity applied to research
just makes no [ __ ] sense at all. Like
you should publish anything that is uh
anything that is like
anything that is like demonstrabably
conducted well. If you like can show
something and you actually have done the
experiments well, it's up to the
research community to determine whether
it is useful or not.
Deciding like, oh, this shouldn't be
published because I don't think it's
like I don't think it's useful enough is
not a good mindset for research.
The selectivity, the problem with
selectivity is people publishing stuff
that is just like poorly done and their
conclusions are invalid.
Not like, oh, we're publishing too many
papers, so we need to be more selective.
[ __ ] bet.
[laughter]
The conferences are mess. All right. Why
is this thing not working at the moment?
probably because
Why the [ __ ] would I want to live in
China?
I mean, to be fair, it's not like I
think our cities are better. Our cities
suck as well, but at least we have nice
suburbs.
I just don't want to live in a city,
period. Like
why? Why?
It's not exactly fair to say China
doesn't innovate, but um the education
system definitely suppresses it a lot
more than the US system does.
I mean, they have way more people
though. Like, they're going to figure it
out and some of them are going to figure
things out in spite of the uh in spite
of the system.
I don't think that the education system
for the most part was particularly
helpful to me. You know, I think I
learned most of the stuff I learned in
spite of it
or maybe too spite of it,
you know,
I don't think you're just going to use
them in like this.
I have no idea what the [ __ ] this is in
the chat.
that we got far better stuff to to worry
about than this though.
Um,
okay. There we go. So,
yeah, that's 1.5 mil with a stupid
architecture though, right?
Yeah, with very stupid architecture.
Do we have policy? We do have the policy
hidden side set here.
So, actually,
if I set to 1.8, is it faster?
Oh, yeah, that's faster. That's 3
million.
We can actually train your MMO nice fast
if we want.
Okay.
So now what do we do with that? Uh
we need the freaking encoder is the
problem.
So the it's just the LSTM and then what
we have encode
decode is nothing right? Yeah, decode is
nothing.
This project
uh project is also nothing
cool. So this needs to be exactly
I mean it's a pretty nice simple little
operation.
just doubled the SPS. Yeah, cuz I cut
the network size down. I was trying to
see if we were full end bottleneck or
not. It seems we're not.
So, presumably we'll actually be able to
have reasonably fast neural MMO. I mean,
I'm suspecting that all the time is
getting lost in this big stupid encoder
here.
Time is this 4:18.
I got another hour and a half.
Uh, I don't need this decoder, do I?
Oh, I do need the decoder. Damn it.
That's fine.
Is there a way to speed it up? We're
going to see. At least, dude, we have
like way better profiling tools than we
had before.
X pale just went up. I don't know. I
haven't been posting a lot of stuff,
dude. I've kind of been staying off of
X. It's been really gross lately.
I have a couple articles I want to
release, but um I've been writing one of
them on language model stuff, but I
think for the most part I'm kind of just
chilling and debing puffer for
everything else is sort of just Nice.
I saw I got like 80 bucks or something
for having barely posted anything this
month. I don't know.
Best article
and whatever.
Well, I mean, if that's real, that's
still a decent speed up.
presumably now we can also like we have
the tools to make this way faster
because we lost half of the speed on
this comp encoder, right?
That's cool though.
That is cool.
So I have to support multidiscreet is
the thing before I can do um
I have to support multidiscreet before I
can do uh the drive environment which I
want to get done. Maybe we will figure
out multidiscreet today.
Like the reason it's annoying, right, is
actually. How the hell do I do this
right now?
this weird freaking sequence pad thing,
right?
Okay.
Um, yeah, that's a bit annoying.
We have this sample logic kernel one
here.
though. I guess since we have a kernel,
hang on.
We might be able to like actually
just have a good kernel to do this
stupid sample off, right?
That would be cool.
A multi- discrete sample kernel.
I think we need one to do it annoyingly.
I'm going to have it port the um while
the context is fresh.
I think that one has like way more
substantial shared in it and [ __ ]
though. We'll see.
There is no
support.
They shipped spark without wait 121
be
130 isn't it?
that one. It actually might need the
cast to be fair.
Not positive.
Oh, it just went ahead and did the
encoder. That's fine.
That's fine. Whatever. That doesn't make
a big difference.
up.
Right now we just have LF LF LF on all
the ends. We'll come up with something
better.
There's quite a bit of custom lock in
there, isn't there?
Yeah, it makes a new end which is not
going to work.
It's kind of complicated.
That's obnoxious.
We can at least start on the multi-
sampling though
of RAM. Ah, okay.
I'll be right back. Use a rest room and
we'll see if we can get multi-discrete
sampler.
Yeah. So the big issue now, right, is
just going to be um
Multi discrete sampling should be like
way faster now though, right?
Yeah,
way faster.
Just needed a custom kernel.
I'm trying to think if I want to do the
custom kernel right now.
Actually, I'm pretty sure I can get
Claude to do it if I describe it exactly
because it's literally
hang on. The sampling op itself is
forward pass only.
It's essentially adding a for loop,
right?
It's literally just adding one for loop.
Well, we the actually the harder thing
is figuring out how we pass in.
We can do this in multiple stages
actually. Yeah, we can do this in
multiple stages.
No actions, right?
Nice.
Oh yeah, bet. I hit um
so my birthday was last week and I got a
before I got sick, I ran a 20 minute
flat three mile, some 640 pace.
That was the other uh bit of exercise
I've been working on lately.
No wonder you got sick. Nah, actually
they kind of gave me some other weird
stuff to do
and it they had some stuff that probably
put some strain on my immune system.
I've been going to the public gym. So
like
no, I'm going to try I'm going to try
something a little bit more chill
tomorrow. Or I'll do like a um
I'll probably do like a 7:30 pace
tomorrow for 3 miles. I think I can man
I'm like I think I can manage that. No
problem.
I'm trying to fix my shoulder as well.
I've been getting some uh I've got like
some PT and some like injury assessment
stuff
and stretches to do.
They basically told me, "Look, your
shoulder's healed. Just have really bad
tendinitis.
How the hell do we make this thing like
how do we handle multiple actions? Here
is what I want to know.
We basically just need a list to loop
over, right?
I think it just is going to end up being
um
like instar n instar length like instar
like counts and then length or
something.
It's all static. So, you can actually
just do this.
going to loop over and that's going to
get us the output shape.
But what's num actions too? Yeah, that's
fine. That's what we want.
Yep. This also makes sense. This needs
to be updated to numb actions. Like so.
It's fine.
I actually don't even know if you need
the numbum. I think you can probably we
can probably just do size of
We'll try that after. We'll do this
first.
Super simple refactors
drive also will need it.
Decoder needs act and for output. Yep.
Make tpple.
sum of sizes for output.
Uh, yes, it does.
It's going to need both.
annoyed it's renamed on actions.
That's fine.
Yeah.
The thing is like I'm happy having this
do it because in my head I know pretty
much exactly what this should look like.
Um, so this is very strongly verifiable
by me sitting here
because I know pretty much exactly what
this should look like.
It needs to just return both of these
things,
the length and the array. And then the
kernel, see, because it's no longer a
tensor op, right? Before we had to do
this padding [ __ ] but now because
we just have a kernel, it's just an
extra loop and it's not a bad loop
either. So this actually this should be
substantially more efficient.
So
let's see first of all
we're going to go look at this and make
sure it doesn't mess this up. This is
important.
Okay. And then it doesn't need to pass
num actions because it gets it from this
stride here.
This is fine. That's actually better.
Okay.
So, it moved this. It should not have
moved this.
I actually don't think it matters that
it moved this, but you know, whatever.
Did it move it outside a loop? No. Okay,
that doesn't matter. Then
find max for numerical stability.
It removed the clamp.
Uh, I don't think it did. Look, it moved
it. It's just hard to read the diff,
dude.
So, look, it just it copied this code
directly under to here, right?
And then here you see the logic offset.
It has the is nan here. It has the exact
same clamp from before.
Okay, it just look this is now going to
be it's going to be this code followed
by this code. So it's exactly what I
said, right? It's this extra loop
num actions and then you loop up to this
to find the max
and then this stays inside. Okay,
everything goes inside this loop. Now
log some x for sol max denominator
which is
You know what I'm going to do? I'm just
going to copy this function here.
I'm going to end up I'm going to keep a
copy of this because we're going to test
uh we're going to test this after.
What? Wait, wait, wait. Hang on. What
the What did it just do?
Oh, no. That's our exact code, right?
Yeah. Yeah. No, this is already our
exact code. Fine.
It just adds this offset.
and then log problem of sampled action.
It just moved this down here.
Yeah. And then this is very small N
bandwidth.
Cool.
Now you're going to see right like look
at this this code. This is what we have
now. You're going to see it's going to
be the same code but in a loop.
Same code in a loop. Right?
So I kind of showed you right that like
it was just going to be a pretty simple
transformation of the existing code.
But like as you can see, a ton of stuff
needs to now be updated because now we
have the launch function.
here. You know, we have these stupid
rappers, right?
And now we have more stupid rappers.
They're in two different places cuz they
have to be cuz cuda to C++ uh boundary.
Uh,
I guess technically they could have made
the
they maybe could have made it so that
the syntax was compatible. It's kind of
tough to know actually. I kind of see
why they have it the way they do
honestly.
The Nvidia stuff's pretty solid.
Oh, look. More launch function [ __ ]
Right. It's four different places that
you need to update this, by the way,
just for the uh the headers. So, that's
this is the fourth one. I think that's
it. I think it's four.
This is now updating the module
signature because there's a torch module
for this as well.
And then there's going to be the call
from C++.
So now you see why I'm using Claude for
this crap, right? You see how much
redundancy there is.
Like Claude would be nowhere near as
helpful
if I had just like a pure CUDA codebase
for instance and I just have this one
place to update stuff. It'd be way
easier doing this type of thing
manually,
right? But basically what I'm using it
for is just applying all these like very
wellescribed transformations to existing
code where you can pretty much tell
exactly what the outcome is going to be.
Right? I'm not telling like go solve
this problem for me. I'm saying well the
problem is going to be solved by this
transformation followed by this
transformation but each of those
requires updating 10 different things. I
don't want to do that manually here.
update those 10 things. And I just
describe each of the transformations
and occasionally prevent it from doing
stupid [ __ ]
Wants to add a tensor for act size.
That's fine. That needs to stay on CUDA.
Do you check its worth carefully? Have
you not wa Have you not been watching me
doing just that?
Yeah. And now it's going to return an
additional act size.
No, because it'll get graphed anyways,
right? And it's not changing. It's
static. That's fine.
It can just be a tensor.
I'm pretty confident that this will be
like not terribly broken cuz it's a very
simple modification. Actually, I thought
this was going to be way worse. It's
kind of funny because I thought of how
terrible this op was in torch, but
actually when you just have a kernel for
it, it's way easier.
Yep. And then it's just wrapped from
blob. That's fine.
See, the only thing that I didn't
predict that I would have realized um
once I'd gone to make the change is that
you don't need to pass the uh the sizes
and the length because the tensor
already has the uh the length
information,
right? Because you can get it from the
stride of the tensor. That's the one
thing I would have missed initially, but
then I would have gotten that as soon as
I started implementing it. Anyways,
We get a good score.
Same as for real assembly.
You went in Hong Kong.
What's he doing in Hong Kong? That's
funny.
San Diego is a very nice place for an
office.
like either like Palo Alto in San Diego
or
very nice.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Not SF. I like Palo Alto
is nice because it's close enough to SF
that you can get there easily
without having to take a quick flight.
But I guess I mean you take a 40-minute
flight, you're an SF, so it's not
terrible either way,
but planes kind of suck.
Okay. Yeah, they fixed it.
Tensor shapes.
They already They already are 2D. We
already did that.
Didn't we do that already?
Oh, the buffer ones are different. Yep,
that's right.
Uh, the buffer ones are in fact
different.
This is how I do that. This is how I do
this, right? Yeah. And this is how I do
this.
You just add one dimension.
Yep, that's fine.
At worst, this will just add a one for
things that are single discrete.
See, this is like my favorite use for it
is just propagating relatively simple
changes like this.
act in
exercises.
credits. Doesn't say I'm out of credits.
That'd be really surprisingly quick as
well.
Oops.
What's going on with this thing?
I'm not dropping frames.
They have an outage or something.
yeah, they have an outage. It looks like
something is broken with their stuff.
So, what we can do is we can just return
the Exercise tensor.
Just do it manually.
The first dimension of act
sizes
Right. So, this now needs numbum
actions.
Where did we make the environments?
We did
let Claude diagnose and fix. They have a
[ __ ] outage, dude. What do you want
me to do?
Lo and behold, I can still write code
myself if need be.
All right. So now we have great graph.
Let's probably change
Okay. Yeah. Before policy, it needs the
number of actions.
You see, it's just like much more
annoying and slow because like it's
shitty C++ that hooks in Lib torch. The
compile time, it takes 15 seconds to
compile. Uh, I'm going to make way more
syntax errors than normal because it's
shitty C++.
Like,
like how important it is to have these
tools as a function of how shitty the
whole setup is.
I don't know why this needs to be like
this
Is this thing done yet? Because it just
like this is its stupid refactor that
has the stupid Context for
Nope. Still broken.
Thanks, Flaw. I get to fix your
[ __ ]
Worthless crap.
Let's get dinner. I have a reservation
for later, dude.
I'm not going now.
Dorsia.
The hell is that?
Oh, some stupidly fancy.
I'm really not into um
I'm really not into that, man.
I don't know. Fine dining goes into the
same like [ __ ] status game treadmill
um in my mind as like Gucci bags and
other dumb [ __ ]
pretty much wherever I am, I find like a
few like like I find a couple like
really casual places with good food and
a couple like, you know, somewhat nicer
places that have good food and then
that's pretty much all I do.
It's not even that it's a waste of
money, dude. Like, it wouldn't even be
like it wouldn't even be interest like
it would still be dumb to me if it if
that weren't remotely a thing, right?
I mean, like I go to the diner a lot,
dude.
There's a diner around here where the uh
the check for two pretty damn like solid
12 ounce New York strips is under 50
bucks.
It's kind of fun not being in freaking
California and wherever.
You could tell me where the dang thing
is, you know.
We'll just let's try with the torch
traces.
Get out of the city. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
What? I That's not what I just What? Why
did this not paste? Oh,
what? Dude,
piss off. Come on.
Yes.
uh from blob.
big storm sitting whole southern US.
See you around.
So much better.
Mhm.
Now it's egg faults. Oh, because this is
the size thing is wrong.
Oh, well, of course it's wrong cuz I
break out.
So, this act size is definitely
supposed to have two elements.
ability.
Yeah.
So, it's this right.
It's like not getting used, I imagine.
Is this stupid thing back yet?
I think this stupid thing is like
screwed up here. I There's probably some
weird DLL thing going on
like right here
possibly.
Okay. So we have numbum actions is two
but then a act size is
Oh yes, that is correct because then
that needs to be moved to later in the
policy.
That needs to go right before we create
the policy.
only needs to tensor before that.
I don't think that needs to go on Cuda
just yet. Then
It's pretty good as well.
Actions.
I've got 25 minutes to get this into a
working state.
And um think we can do that. If we can
get target working that'd be super nice
because that's multi- aent
multi-discreet.
So that would pretty much mean we have
the machinery for everything except this
fancy shared M's and continuous actions
8 hour streams. I'm back to like 90%
probably. I've been live eight and a
half hours.
Action. Select
one.
Oh, I see what it's going to do. Um,
yeah, that's annoying.
Actions dot.
I don't think that's correct.
View batch
minus one.
I mean, I don't see how this wouldn't be
a colonel.
Presumably, it's bound to C++.
Oh yeah, I forgot we have this [ __ ]
logistics to props thing as well.
Oh no, that's a torch function, isn't
it?
mention being sick.
I mean, I had a couple good workouts
right before
He had dimension already be there in
this
Why the Why the hell is it like this,
dude?
It's odd.
One moment.
assisting on a larger code base.
It's actually more useful on the large
code base. Um, precisely because there's
a lot of unavoidable [ __ ] going on
here.
It's actually less useful on my smaller
codebase, believe it or not.
Like the reason that this is useful now
is that there is there are like three
different versions of things that are
just getting ported to APIs in different
languages. There are uh like there's
like sevenfold redundancy on headers and
things because there are three different
languages here plus tests
and a lot of the operations are just
like pretty simple um transformations of
the code that just have a lot of
redundancy and I think I can reduce some
of that but there's still going to end
up being like a fair bit of redundancy
around. It's going to at least be my
promise to you all will be that this uh
the source code here will be
dramatically dramatically easier to
follow than the torch source and faster.
That I can guarantee you.
I'm going to get it as good as I can and
also I'm going to expose like big chunks
of it uh to Python.
Well, I think we already handle the one
at the end for value, right?
Okay, it's already returned like this.
Then we're fine.
Okay, this is fine. This is a transpose
over each, right?
I think this is the same as our code
now, right?
Yeah, the transpose is fine. That
matches our code. There is one for loop.
It's fine. Add sequence
shouldn't need this multomial. Don't you
have
See, this is like the limit of what it
can do. You see how much it's struggling
here? It keeps proposing stupid [ __ ]
like, "Ah, yeah, I got it this time.
Yes. It does need multi-iscrete support
if we don't use the kernel.
Okay. So now it knows
did forward call first with action.
equals none.
Okay. And then what we do
That's fine. This [ __ ] is getting
graphed. Anyways,
Honestly, it's better to model
separately, isn't it?
Yeah.
So now we have this thing
and now we can check these separately
which is good.
Take this one is done.
I don't like this chunk of code though.
It's such a mess.
I mean, this kind of like the fact that
it gets this complicated kind of just
tells you that the torch is a mess.
Okay, it just put it here
and then I put this one here.
So, I don't know about this
multi-discrete path working or not yet.
Um, we'll be able to test this. If we
can just in the next few minutes have a
working version of this that still
trains breakout, that would be nice. so
I can make a commit.
I got a whole bunch of stuff done today.
But yeah, this stuff just it's Hey, this
is just like black hole for time. Um,
this update's just a ton of work.
I mean, even with Claude going through
and like applying these changes,
there's just stupid stupid amounts of
stuff in this
Okay, good. It wasn't that much to ask
for and we get it. We have breakout
still running,
so we can make a nice commit and be in a
clean spot for today.
That's good.
I always add everything manually. So I'd
like I force myself to actually make
sure I know what the hell I'm
committing.
It's very easy to mess up
committing all
That's a lot of stuff actually now I'm
looking at it.
Oh, we also have all the uh the end of
updates, right?
So, the next stream will most likely be
either tomorrow night or
um or Saturday.
I'm going to be live all day all day
Saturday. So,
probably I'm going to rest a little
tomorrow night
and uh you know be ready to do the all
day all day Saturday stream.
One moment. Let me I'll do a outro in a
second
and we'll make sure we have everything.
So, because you guys can play with this
if you want. It's like getting to be
more stable. Still needs a ton of work,
but I mean this is like way better.
Okay, there you go. Nine hour stream.
I am pretty happy with that. Um, man,
for folks who've been watching, come
back Saturday, maybe tomorrow night. If
you're interested in my stuff, I stream
all my dev. Um, at least all the public
dev. I also have some client work I do
offream.
If you want to help me out for
absolutely free, feed this puff or a
star on GitHub. We're almost to 5,000.
If you want to get involved with
development, most of it is less
absolutely insane than what I'm doing
now. Like you can just do low-level
gamedev and learn RL in the process and
contribute to science and research and
start learning some of the stuff I'm
doing as well in the process.
All these M's, well, most of these M's
are by contributors here.
You can also follow me on X for more RL
content, including some articles that
I'm working on you can't find anywhere
else. All my educational materials are
there as well.